Okay, so we heard you were in New York.
I know your schedule.
You're probably being raced from one place to another.
Yeah.
Right?
Not a ton of downtime.
It's been pretty busy,
but it's been a lot of fun.
But I have been searching for the ultimate bagel,
and it looks like we have some great varieties here.
Okay.
So I, we dug deep,
and we have three different types of bagels in front of us
and we're going to each taste them.
If you like, this is not a forced situation.
Yeah, yep.
And I wanna hear your thoughts.
So first we have a classic lox and cream cheese bagel
from the authentic and genuinely
one of the most wonderful establishments
Russ and Daughters, if you are.
(audience clapping)
Oh okay.
That's, okay so Russ and Daughters
has been around since 1914,
and they're known for their smoked fish
while also serving up the classic bagel and lox combination.
Are you a lox or no lox?
Yes, I'm definitely lox.
I'm everything.
Let's do it.
All right, so you're gonna lox.
Do I give it out of 10 or something?
All right.
Yes, by the way, we should have thought of that.
Cheers.
I'm going no lox.
Okay.
All right.
Lox locks, 'cause lox originated in Scandinavia
in the 19th century.
Oh, all right.
That's darn good lox.
Oh, wow.
What do you think?
No?
I don't like the cream cheese.
Oh, okay.
I like it, it's a classic, right.
A modern classic.
I love how I said I don't like the cream cheese
and then just took a big lick of more cream cheese.
A bit of lemon on that would be nice.
Yes.
Right.
It would be,
a little acid.
What's this flat one?
What's wrong with that?
It's a flatz bagel,
and it has veggie cream cheese from Zuckers Bagels
and smoked fish.
And that also is a very-
cheers.
Is that a thing, bagel, cheers?
I don't know.
I don't know it, it should be.
We made it.
Okay, here we go.
How dare somebody not.
I'm gonna look in your eyes when we do this.
(audience cheers)
What is it about the smoked fish and schmear
that's got you all hot Sam?
Yeah, I'm not sure, but damn it tastes good.
Yeah.
I'll just feed you and, and you,
no nevermind.
Which which love scene had cream cheese and bagels?
None ever.
I know they should.
Did you ever watch Seinfeld?
Remember when George Costanza
was always trying to figure out how to have sex
and eat a sandwich at the same time?
(audience laughing)
We worked it out.
This is for George Costanza.
For George.
No, that is really nice.
That's really rich.
What is this?
Okay.
Mammoth thing.
This is our novelty jumbo bagel.
It's from Hoboken, New Jersey.
(audience cheering)
Ah.
It looks a little intimidating, I guess.
Yeah.
Just
Oh, just do it.
This the fire hog spread.
Oh, Sam it's getting sexier.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Can I do this?
Can I feed you?
I feel like a baby bird.
What happened?
I think this bagels got some,
it's, this is a lot.
Here comes the bagel.
(audience laughing)
We don't have to do this.
Okay, go on, go on.
Go on Drew.
Yes.
That was supposed to rip away from your hand.
And instead of course, I just took the whole bagel with me.
Like I was supposed to be baby bird
and it turned into vulture.
That's very soft.
No?
It's softer than the other one.
It's very doughy.
Well, that was something else.
I can't get it down.
Sure.
Okay.
Oh, here.
Cheers, yeah.
Oh here cheers.
Orange juice.
Is this a classic that goes with bagels or?
Oh wow.
Let's vote.
Yeah, let's vote.
What was your favorite bagel?
That was tough, but the classic obviously, excellent.
I kind of like the flat one.
This one is amazing for a party
or an ice hockey team,
but this is the winner.
Oh my God, we have the same bagel.
We have the same bagels.
I like the nice flat sat on bagel.
Yeah, me too.
This is the kind of bagel,
I feel like if I didn't know it was meant to be like this
I would think that something was wrong,
but it turns out it's the best one of the bunch
It is.
And I guess, cheers.
Thanks for bringing me to the best bagel in New York.
It's my pleasure.
Yeah.
And I just have to tell you,
I'm so happy to like hang out with you.
I'm so happy to be a part of the Hooligans now.
(audience clapping)
We all see what all the fuss is about.
You've been doing this show for years.
People are so loyal.
They are so obsessed with it,
and you're bringing everybody so much joy.
Oh, thank you.
We really enjoy our job.
And yeah, we're really excited
for obviously the premiere and everyone
to see the hard work.
So-
And I heard that season six people are upset
because of COVID,
you only have a certain amount of episodes,
but you're gonna to come back
with season seven with even more.
(audience cheering)
Well, that's true, yeah.
Yeah, we are.
Is that true?
Yeah, we're doing, we're doing an extra eight next season.
We're do 16 next season.
But actually this season
even the first episode is a feature length.
It's an hour and a half long
and there will be other episodes that are also longer.
So I don't think it feels smaller.
In fact, a lot happens this season.
(upbeat music)